I work in the Directorate General for
economic and financial affairs as an
economist I working on fiscal policy so
specifically on budgetary surveillance
and mainly on the implementation of the
stability and growth pact I did a
commercial engineering and then
afterwards a PhD in economics after the
PhD I started teaching first at the
University of Amsterdam and then I
switched to research at the National
Bank of Belgium in my job we need many
skills actually academic expertise work
on public finances we need a lot of
legal thinking because we are applying
law and sometimes we also had to make
law and we need of course a lot of
political awareness the European aspect
in particular interested me a lot first
of all because as an economist you can't
really get around the International
aspect and for European economies who
mainly trade and produce and integrate
with each other that means that there is
a naturally very strong European
dimension what fascinates me most on a
day-to-day basis is that I'm not only
learning through my work and through the
challenges that that are brought up but
I'm learning through the interaction
with people with interesting and really
knowledgeable people we work primarily
in English but we can also happen to
work in French and in the corridors for
sure you will hear tons of other
languages Spanish in Dalian and living
in Brussels is is really fun so I think
it's a really good sized town to be
living in it's big enough that there's a
lot to do both culturally but also
restaurants bars I really love working
in Brussels and living in Brussels I
think it's fantastic place I think it's
a very open and free minded and a modern
city the fact that there are so many
people working for the institutions but
also in jobs related to them means that
it's a very international City I think
working here is is a really fascinating
stimulating thing to do on a personal
level it's it's very rewarding because
you get to meet fantastic people from
all over the world and I think you can
contribute to something that that
ultimately touches upon all our lives
here in Europe